es war das geradezu ikonische Bild aus
der Anfangszeit der Ampel ein selfie
bärburg hab Wissing selig vereint 27
Monate später samt andauernden
Rosenkrieg wollen manche schon das
sterbe glücklein der
ftschittskoalition vernommen haben weil
auch der Hausvater Olaf Scholz nicht
eben glücklich agiert bei alem ist
Deutschland aber auch nicht in Auflösung
begriffen oder gar
untergegangen im Umfragetief ist die
Ampel so schlecht wie ihr Ruf jetzt in
der
phönixrunde
[Musik]
phönixrunde herzlich Willkommen bei uns
meine Gäste eva gartbeck ist bei uns
Chefredakteurin und Leiterin der
hauptstadtredaktion des
redaktionsnetzwerks Deutschland rnd ein
Verbund regionaler Medien Sigmund
Gottlieb ehemaliger Chefredakteur des
Bayerischen Fernsehens Kolumnist und
Podcaster der Podcast trägt den Titel
gegen den Strom und ihr aktuelles Buch
heißt so nicht Klartext zur Lage der
Nation Professor KL Rudolf Korte
Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität Duisburg Essen und Direktor
der NRW School of Governance und
schließlich Frank Staus bei uns
Politikberater und Wahlkampfmanager sie
haben zahlreiche Wahlkämpfe für die SPD
geführt bei diesem Thema fragt man oft
am Ende der Sendung die Frage die ich
jetzt am Anfang Stelle wie lange hält
eigentlich die Ampel noch hält sie bis
2025 bis zum Ende der Legislaturperiode
ja nein ja aber ich würde sagen
tendenziell sie hält also alle drei
Partner wollen nicht auseinander gehen
weil die Wahlergebnisse wären ja dann
wie aktuell die Umfragewerte sind
nämlich verheerend aber ich halte es
auch nicht für ausgeschlossen dass es zu
einer Art Ermüdungsbruch kommen könnte
also dass die Koalition ohne es zu
wollen tatsächlich dann doch in solche
eine Regierungskrise stolpert dass sie
darüber zerbricht ihr Auftragsbuch wird
wahrscheinlich anders aussehen wenn
vorher schon die Bundeswahl stad
Bundestagswahl stattfindet dasus was
meinen Sie nein die hält bis zum Schluss
oder vielleicht sogar bis zur Wiederwahl
heute nahzu unvorstellbar aber es ist
eine lange Zeit und wir haben schon
viele Überraschungen erlebt her Kel ja
ich sehe das ähnlich 75 Jahre
Grundgesetz wenn man sich das in die
Hand nimmt sieht man wie dieses Gesetz
auf Stabilität ausgerichtet ist und sehr
voraussetzungsvoll ist eine vorzeitige
Bundestagswahl überhaupt hinzubekommen
das kann man nicht einfach ausrufen und
insofern sehe ich auch vom Prozedere da
kein Mechanismus der greifen würde also
macht sie vorher schlapp nein in der
Frage sehe ich auch keinen Konflikt in
dieser in dieser Runde es wird so
bleiben wie es ist dazu gibt es auch
viel zu viele Interessenslagen vor allem
in den Fraktionen das sind Abgeordnete
die Leben auch von ihren Mandaten die
wollen nicht dass das vorher aufhört und
ich glaube ist ein ganz pragmatischer
Grund und ich glaube auch dass D
die die führenden Vertreter der
Koalition das jetzt so weiter machen
werden sie wursteln sich jetzt im Grunde
zum Beginn des Wahlkampfes hin wir
sollten jetzt auch nicht mehr große
politische themenfindungen erwarten für
die nächsten Monate gut sie sind sich
einig in dieser Runde das heißt in den
nächsten etwa 18 Monaten wird im Titel
der phöigsrundensendung noch häufiger
der Name Ampel auftauchen Frau gotbeck
im ZDF Politbarometer erreicht die
Koalition gerade ihren nächsten
Tiefpunkt 69% sind der Meinung dass die
Bundesregierung eher schlechte Arbeit
leistet diese Ablehnungshaltung diese
klare Mehrheit die
Regierungsarbeit so zu verdammen ist das
gerechtfertigt ja wir haben es ja mit
mehr zu tun als
mit dem Ärger der Leute über eine
handwerklich schlecht agierende
Regierung es muss man ja schon
konstatieren dass wir hier schon eine
Krise der Institution Regierung haben
also das Vertrauen der Leute dass die
Regierung überhaupt die aktuellen
Probleme der Zeit lösen kann das ist
dahin also das ist sehr stark gesunken
das kann man ja auch wenn man sich
solche Umfragen etwas genauer anguckt
durchaus aus den Details herauslesen und
das Vertrauen zurückzugewinnen da
fürchte ich dass der Ampel das nicht
gelingen wird weil ihre innere verfass
nicht gut genug dafür ist also der
innere Zusammenhalt ist so schlecht dass
ich nicht sehe dass es noch mal ein
eigenen Projekt gibt mit dem sie sich am
eigenen Schopf aus dem Sumpf ziehen
könnte und deshalb muss man sagen diese
Werte spiegeln schon auch eine
dramatische Lage da was eben das
Vertrauen der Leute insgesamt
angeht selbst der Bundes Präsident hat
ja die Ampelkoalition zur Ordnung
gerufen ist das vor allen ein
Kommunikations was man immer wieder hört
wir haben auch handwerkliche Mängel
gerade gehört als einen möglichen Grund
ja das ist das ist so ein Thema das muss
man vorsichtig angehen oder vielleicht
auch deutlich angehen oder beides denn
Kommunikationsfehler werden dann gemacht
wenn die Politik an sich gut ist dann
kann eine schlechte Kommunikation dafür
sorgen dass die Politik schlecht
verkauft wird aber es handelt sich hier
ja äh um eine
Politik die in der jüngsten Zeit viele
viele Fehler gemacht hat und ob ich
jetzt da kommuniziere oder nicht
kommuniziere ist eigentlich zweitrangig
da verstehe ich auch die Hartnäckigkeit
von Olaf Scholz sehr gut der sich
vergleichsweise wenig um Kommunikation
kümmert auch wenn er es sollte aber es
ist kein Kommunikationsproblem da bin
ich zutiefst davon überzeugt sondern ein
Problem der schlechten Substanz dieser
Politik und man kann sie Frau Quadbeck
finde ich an einem Thema festmachen und
wenn das gelöst würde oder ansatzweise
gelöst würde dann würde sich auch in den
Umfragen etwas ändern das ist das Thema
Zuwanderung und Migration und dafür hat
es eben bisher noch keinen
Beweis gegeben dass diese Koalition das
liefert wenn das jetzt geschehen sollte
es gibt ja einige Anzeichen wir wollen
ja auch hier nicht alles schlecht reden
dann glaube ich würden sich auch die
umfrageerte äh verändern ST jetzt äh wir
die Leistung des Bundeskanzlers auch
sehr negativ bewertet 28% finden ihn nur
noch gut das ist ein historischer ein
historisch schlechtes Ergebnis liegt das
eben auch daran dass sich Olaf Scholz
auf eine Koalition mit Partnern
eingelassen hat die eigentlich nicht
wirklich zusammenpen und die relativ
schnell nach diesem selfie gemerkt haben
dass sie nicht zusammengehören und
deswegen auch keine Freude aneinander
haben denke die Erwartungshaltung der
Menschen an Olaf Scholz war eben die die
letztendlich auch zu ihrer
Wahlentscheidung geführt hat zu seinem
Wahlsieg wenn auch mit bescheidenen
Prozenten muss man ja auch dazu sagen ja
war natürlich dass
eine Seriösität eine Orientierung äh
Substanz und Verlässlichkeit
äh in dieser Person liegen die sie
letztendlich dazu bewogen hat ihn über
Armin laschit oder über Frau berbur zu
stellen in diesem Wahlkampf und
letztendlich ich würde zunächst mal auch
bestreiten dass die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung tatsächlich dies diese
Koalition haben wollte ich glaube zu dem
Zeitpunkt der Wahl wollte sie eigentlich
am liebsten eine große Koalition unter
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und insofern
eigentlich eher eine Verlängerung dieser
16 Jahre davor ich glaube es gab keinen
großen Reformwillen in der Bevölkerung
und insofern ist die Erschütterung jetzt
so groß weil er genau das nicht liefert
und das ist sehr gefährlich für ihn
sie haben es richtig benannt es liegt
auch in der Substanz der Parteien selbst
die zum Teil wirklich diametrale
politische Überzeugungen tragen
nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich an der
Stelle aber auch mal sagen dass die
allgemeine Krisensituation in der wir
uns bewegen ja nicht eine deutsches
Phänomen ist und die Krise der
Demokratie und die Krise der
Volksparteien ist auch kein deutsches
Phänomen das heißt es kommen im Moment
zwei Dinge zusammen eine große
Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung und
eine Regierung die aus S der Bevölkerung
keine Orientierung bietet und das ist
die große Gefahr auch für die
Kanzlerschaft wir sind ja auch gewohnt
stabile Verhältnisse zu haben auch auch
in Krisen anders als andere Länder um
uns herum Karl Rudolf Karte jetzt sieht
man an der an den Protesten der landwrte
die ja jedenfalls einige ziemlich
lautstark aggressiv vollmundig auch
vorgehen wie es im Moment aussieht im
Land zu einer anderen Zeit die nicht so
aufgeheizt ist nicht so aggressiv in der
Stimmung nicht nicht nur wegen der Frage
der
landwirtschaftspension wäre in einer
anderen
Zeit werden diese Proteste nicht so
aggressiv nicht so ja so übergriffig
also das
staatsverächtliche in der Tonalität und
Inhalt ist schon auch in die Mitte der
Gesellschaft eingedrungen und sofern ist
das Klima der Auseinandersetzung rauer
und auch staatsverächtlicher als es
früher der Fall war aber in zwei Monaten
diskutieren wir über was anderes und
Widerstand und Gegensätze irgendwie
auszuhalten das mussten andere Regierung
auch und vor ein paar Monaten gab es
auch schon Krise da haben die Hessen und
die Bayern gewählt und haben 85% mittig
gewählt haben mit über 30% eine
traditionelle Volkspartei in die
Verantwortung genommen also ich schließe
auch nicht aus dass nicht nur dieser
immer schlimmerismus
am Ende regiert sondern wir auch die
Sympathiewerte einer Regierung
verbessern können durch das was er
gottlib vorhin angedeutet hat dass man
Problemlösung hinbekommt Vertrauen der
Regierung gegenüber der Regierung hängt
von Problemlösung und von
Verlässlichkeit ab bisher haben wir den
Eindruck dass er punktuell regiert wird
und Vereinbarung nicht eingehalten
werden also beide Punkte die
Hauptprobleme zu bearbeiten und das
verlässlich zu machen was spricht
dagegen dass eine Regierung sich noch
mal zusammenrauft und das auch
hinbekommt Frau qu da würde ich gerne
uns beide auch mal sie und mich
ansprechen ich überlege mir immer wieder
woher kommt eigentlich diese ungedulde
Bürger und Bürgerin woher kommt das und
das kommt natürlich zum Teil daher dass
der Großteil der Medien einen
Zeithorizont und einen Zeitzwang aufbaut
der nicht mehr realistisch ist bei der
Komplexität der Themen die wir im
Augenblick haben also wenn ich am Montag
ein Problem habe und es ist nicht am
Donnerstag dieser Woche sozusagen
innerhalb der Koalition gelöst dann gibt
es einen massiven Druck der Medien und
dann gibt es im Grunde da auch die
entsprechende Reflexion der Bürger und
sagen ja die haben ja eigentlich recht
warum ist das nicht gelöst und dann gibt
es diesen ganz
Verdruss der sich dann auch kanalisiert
in Richtung AFD und andere das scheint
mir ein also ein Stück Selbstkritik
jetzt auch zu sein zu sagen ist es
eigentlich realistisch ständig diesen
diesen tempodruck aufzubauen in einer
Zeit die das nicht mehr verträgt will
will ich will die Selbstkritik der
Medien nicht beiseite wischen aber an
ein paar mit ein paar konkreten
Beispielen doch Widers sprechen also
Beispiel heizungsgesetz da hat die
Bundesregierung wirklich ein halbes Jahr
rumgemurst sind mit einem Gesetzentwurf
rausgegangen wo noch keiner ein
Gesetzentwurf erwartet hat und auch gar
nicht gebraucht hat in diesem Moment und
dann sind sie die getriebenen geworden
ihrer schlechten handwerklichen Politik
anderes Beispiel die Regierung
verspricht 400.000 neue Wohnungen pro
Jahr 100.000 davon sollen
Sozialwohnungen sein kriegt sie nicht
hin unrealistisches versprechen und dann
das nächste Beispiel beim Urteil jetzt
des Verfassungsgerichts aus Karlsruhe
dass der Haushalt so nichtig ist wie er
aufgestellt worden ist da war die
kommentarlage durchaus so dass die
Regierung sich jetzt mal Zeit nehmen
soll dass man sich in Ruhe überlegen
soll äh wie man eigentlich damit umgeht
und ob man nicht doch vielleicht eine
Reform der Schuldenbremse äh in
irgendeiner Form beschließt aber da hat
sich die Regierung dann selbst den Druck
gemacht weil sie nämlich nicht wollten
dass der Lindner mit einem vorläufigen
Haushalt so viel Macht in der Regierung
bekommt deshalb ich will diese Kritik
nicht beiseite wischen und die Medien
sind Katalysatoren und wenn eine Lage
schlecht ist dann wird sie durch die
Medien sicherlich no stimm mit dem mit
der Klick Parade das war in in den
Online Medien im Internet in den Social
Media Kanälen da eben die Medien auchag
jeden Tag eine andere Saks DF jagen
müssen da muss man auf jeden Fall
differenzieren zwischen Social Media auf
der einen Seite wo dann jeder sein
eigener Publisher werden kann und wo ja
dann auch sehr viel Druck aus der
Bevölkerung und von Menschen kommt die
nicht professionell medienagierende sind
sondernind
medienternehmenind Unternehmen unterwegs
aber da würde ich mal behaupten die
traditionellen Medienmarken die achten
schon darauf dass ähm natürlich
muss Social Media catchy sein in dem
Sinne dass die Leute
da gerne drauf klicken und sich
anschauen was sich dahinter verbirgt es
muss aber dadurch nicht sofort unseriös
sein im Sinne von dass eine Lage
dramatisch anders dargestellt wird als
sie aber Politik im krisenmodus muss ja
auch ein Modus des veränderns des
Experimentierens des feuerlöschens
praktisch immer haben umso wichtiger ist
eine kohärente begleitende Kommunikation
wir können in einer komplexen
Gesellschaft nicht von einem 160 Seiten
dicken Gesetz erwarten dass es alle
Probleme löst das war in einer
Gesellschaft die zyklischer oder
linearer aufgebaut ist einfacher nach
vier Wochen poppt an einer Stelle wieder
ein Problem auf umso wichtiger ist es
wenn es um Problemlösung geht dies auch
mit einer schlüssigen Kommunikation zu
begleiten das gibt es aber nicht bei
dieser Regierung aber wenn wir jetzt
das Erscheinungsbild der Koalition
kritisiert wird wie man sich in der
Öffentlichkeit gibt also etwas polemisch
ausgedrückt wie ein antiautoritärer
Kinderladen im Westberlin der 1970er
Jahre und Herr stausmann dann eigentlich
konstatiert warum sind die eigentlich
angetreten sie haben es gerade schon
erklärt es lag ja auch an dem Zustand
dem ziemlich desolaten Zustand der Union
im Jahre
2021 aber dass man wenn man in einer
Koalition ist ein Koalitionsvertrag
abschließt sich ein Programm gibt das
anpackt unterschiedliche Interessen
Ausgleich diskutiert da gibt's ein
unglaublich kompliziertes erfahren aber
dann wenn man es beschlossen hat auch
hinter dieser Entscheidung der Koalition
insgesamt steht und genau das passiert
ja nicht dann geht's ja erst richtig los
auf offener Bühne wie gesagt
antiautoritärer Kinderladen aus den 70er
Jahren ist man ist das den Koalitionären
egal dieses Entscheid bild oder sagen
die ich kann meine Schäfchen am besten
ins Trockene bringen wenn ich so agiere
wie ich jetzt agiere mit den fatalen
Ergebnis von Umfragen in denen alle drei
Koalitionsparteien noch nicht mal auf
die Stimmenanzahl von Unionsparteien
kommen zunächst mal war es ja nicht
immer so und man muss ja auch noch mal
rückblickend sehen diese Regierung wurde
im Dezember 21 vereidigt und im Februar
des folgenden Jahres begann der
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine das heißt
man war ja sofort im krisenm Modus man
war in einem Modus in dem man die größte
Energiewende in der Geschichte der
Republik letztendlich auch vorbereitet
hat und man war auch sofort im Diskurs
in einem sehr harten Diskurs denken Sie
mal an die ganze Frage der
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine dann
noch die die die damals schon schon
wichtige Rede von von Scholz zur
Zeitenwende da hat ja diese Regierung
innerhalb von kürzester Zeit sehr
dramatische und sehr eingreifende
Entscheidungen getroffen und
letztendlich das Land ja auch gut durch
diese anderthalb Jahre wo ja große
Ungewissheiten bestanden geführt der
eigentliche Knackpunkt für mich war
glaube ich die tatsächlich dieses
heizungsgesetz über das wir gesprochen
hatten weil und da möchte ich noch mal
ganz kurz auf den mediendiskurs
zurückkommen ich glaube die Rolle der
Medien wird allgemein heute noch
überschätzt
denn wir erleben ja in der Bevölkerung
gerade zwei sehr sehr gegensätzliche
Entwicklungen wir erleben auf der einen
Seite eine Popularisierung oder eine
Radikalisierung und auf der anderen
Seite erleben wir einen sehr starken
Eskapismus das heißt ein sich ausklinken
aus der Medienwelt aus der
Berichterstattung das heißt immer mehr
Menschen da hat auch natürlich mit der
Entwicklung der Streamingdienste und
viele andere Dinge zu tun sehen sich gar
keine Nachrichten mehr an und und
gleichzeitig ziehen sie sich immer
stärker zurück in ihr zause und jetzt
kommt ein Gesetz das ganz ganz massiv in
das Zuhause eingreift und man darf auch
nicht vergessen bei den Krisen die wir
in den Jahren zuvor hatten Eurokrise und
so weiter und so fort selten hat eine
Krise von Corona abgesehen die eigenen
vier wänd so erreicht wie jetzt
infolge des angriffskriegs gegen die
Ukraine beispielsweise die Inflation das
heißt wir haben es tatsächlich ein
spürbare Veränderung die manche Dinge
war abstrakt da hat man gesagt okay man
gibt jetzt irgendeinem Land Kredite aber
letztendlich hat man es gar nicht
gespürt aber solche Dinge wie die
Inflation wie die man sofort gemerkt hat
sie haben die die Frage des Wohnungsbaus
angesprochen ich glaube zu dem Zeitpunkt
des Versprechens war das realistisches
versprechen aber es war es eben halbes
Jahr später nicht mehr weil es eben auch
durch die Inflation massive Einwirkungen
auf den Immobilienmarkt hatte und dann
kam eben dieses Gesetz und das war zum
Beginn Pfusch und jetzt erleben wir
leider in der Folge eine Regierung wo
ich bei ihnen bin die den Eindruck
erwckt als ob jeder für sich kämpft und
die gleichzeitig jetzt bei dem aktuellen
Entwicklung ja wieder gepfuscht hat und
das ist das Problem wenn es zum
Wiederholen kommt weil es war es war
keine es war keine sofortige re Aktion
der Bevölkerung im Gegenteil das war
eigentlich eine sehr langsame nur jetzt
kamen zwei Brüche innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit wo die Menschen auch das
Gefühl hatten die Regierung macht etwas
dann wird von fünf Traktoren gehubt und
sie nimmt wieder zurück und das aber das
istit wir ja bei den handwerklichen
Fehlern sind das heizungsgesetz ist ja
das prekärste Beispiel aber Herr Staus
ich würde das auch also ich würde zwei
Begriffe würde ich aus der Diskussion
nehmen wollen weil sie diesen auch
teilversagen diese Regierung nicht
gerecht werden einmal dass es sich nur
um handwerkliche Fehler handelt das sind
schwere handwerkliche Fehler gewesen die
dann zu den entsprechenden Folgen
geführt haben und das ist zweitens eben
haben wir Anfang darüber gesprochen nur
ein Kommunikationsproblem ist du kannst
ein schlechtes heizungsgesetz nicht gut
kommunizieren du kannst am besten gar
nichts mehr kommunizieren so schlecht
ist das gewesen und da kommt für mich
ein Punkt
hinzu den ich diese Regierung allen äh
Teilnehmer dieser Regierung vorhalten
muss es ist ein dramatisches
empathiefizit sie können sich in ihren
Lebenswelten in Berlin oder anderswo in
den Wahlkreisen nicht mehr vorstellen
wie es den Menschen die nichts oder
wenig haben tatsächlich geht und was sie
denen zumuten mit einer solchen äh
Gesetzesverordnung das können die sich
nicht mehr vorstellen und wenn eine
Regierung das nicht mehr kann dann hat
sie den Kontakt zum Boden und den
Kontakt zu den Leuten verloren was man
jetzt auch bei den bauernprotesten
wieder sieht das ist vielleicht keine
Klientel den es besonders schlecht geht
aber die sich überfahen manchen schon
das kommt auch auf die
landwirtschaftliche Struktur an im Süden
ist die anders als im Norden von
Deutschland aber es ist eben auch das
Gefühl bei diesen Menschen gewesen bei
den Landwirten sie werden überfahren
Grundvertrauen ist nicht da durch die
vielen Krisen und die Menschen sind auch
erschöpft und haben das Gefühl niemand
hört auf sie und es gibt einfach
Beispiele es hat sich bis zur Wahl in
Wiesbaden und in München nicht wirklich
beim Thema Migration irgendwas bewegt
aber in allen Umfragen ist das das
Hauptthema was die Menschen beschäftigt
und plötzlich nach der Wahl bewegt sich
was und da merken die Leute niemand
hörte irgendwie auf uns vorher jetzt hat
sich etwas machtpolitisch offenbar
verändert da wird auf uns gehört also
dieses paternalistisches etwas was viele
stört dass man sich einsam allein und
erschöpft vorkommt und nicht in
irgendeiner Weise durch das
Grundvertrauen als sicherheitsdeutsche
wo man in dem man auch immer gerne wählt
abgeholi ich beim Thema Migration ja
tatsächlich jetzt wieder nichts bewegt
immer ja aber es war zumindest ein paar
Wochen so sah aus und es kommt etwas
strukturelles hinzu sie haben mit dem
selfie Bild damals vorhin angefangen die
diese zitruskoalition die ja die junge
Leute vor allen gewählt haben ne die
Grünen und die gelben das war schon
Aufbruch das war eine Erwartungshaltung
nach diesem langen Diskurs alle die
furchtbare große Koalition das konnte
niemand mehr ertragen und da war das
schon eine Bewegung die in der
fortschrittsthatik angelegt war aber ein
wir haben noch nie einen Kanzler mit so
einem schwachen Mandat gewählt mit
25,7 und noch nie eine Kanzlerpartei
gehabt die strukturell immer in der
Minderheit ist wenn die anderen sich
gegen ihn verbünden also Faktoren die
Besonderheiten sind bei dieser Ampel die
man einfach auch berücksichten muss und
dass sie grundsätzlich unterschiedliche
Interessen haben entspricht durchaus dem
wederw will wir haben auch im Parlament
wir haben acht Parteien mit Mandaten
vergeben ein Parlament voller
Singularitäten geradezu wir wollen dass
Unterschiede am Ende sich aber
verständigen aber den Schritt weiter den
hat die Regierung danach nicht gemacht
die Frage wie man aus Fehlern lernt Herr
Staus
jetzt soll ja am und vor allen Dingen
wie man Vertrauen zurückgewinnt
und dass die Leute in Zukunft auch
wieder Vertrauen gewinnen jetzt soll am
Donnerstag einerseits im
haushaltsbereinigungsgesetz klargezogen
werden es bleibt bei der schrittweisen
bei dem schrittweisen Abbau der
Subvention von Agrardiesel aber Rolf
Mütze nicht der SPD
Fraktionsvorsitzender der gestern
versprochen man will den Bauern
gleichzeitig gegenkommen in man
strukturelle Änderungen zu ihrer
Entlastung finanziellen bürokratischen
Entlastung bringt ist da wenn das jetzt
wieder nicht funktioniert wenn man da
leere Versprechungen macht ist es ja
noch fataler für die amtlich ich weiß
gar nicht ob das eine lere Versprechung
ist oder nicht der Punkt ist dass die
Menschen einfach in diesen Zeiten in
denen sie wirklich sehr
umgetrieben werden in denen immer
weniger Planbarkeit in ihrem Leben
herrscht schon den Eindruck haben
möchten dass Sie Regierung einen Plan
hat und jetzt hat man natürlich wieder
das Gefühl es wird was nachgeschossen im
um etwas zu reparieren was wer schief
gegangen ist ich glaube um die FR aber
ich bin auch bei Professor Korte um zu
sagen es kann Vertrauen noch
zurückgewonnen werden wenn diese
Regierung tatsächlich zusammenarbeitet
und das würde ich sogar appellieren hat
mehr damit zu tun als jetzt ihre eigene
wiedderwahl oder was auch immer zu
ermöglichen sondern wir leben in einer
Zeit in der man sich tatsächlich unter
diesem demokratischen Parteien eine
unheitliche Regierung nicht leisten kann
weil wir sind tatsächlich in einer ich
habe es auch schon angesprochen auch
international gesehen in einer Phase in
der Demokratien einfach unter Beschuss
sind wir haben jetzt noch mal neue
Parteien die auch noch mal auf die
Bildfläche kommen das heißt das was
Professor Korte angesprochen hat die
Zersplitterung des Parlaments zieht
eventuell weitere Kreise und deswegen
würde ich an die
drei wichtigsten Personen in dieser
Ampel tatsächlich appellieren sagen es
geht nicht mal mehr nur um eure
Regierung es geht tatsächlich darum wie
die Demokratie in diesem Land betrachtet
wird und ihr habt die verdammte Pflicht
zusammen zuarbeiten und dieses Land
tatsächlich gemeinsam und zusammen zu
regieren und wenn das der letzte
Warnschuss ist dann dann der dass man
wirklich sagt es geht nicht nur um euch
sondern wir sind in einer wirklich
schwierigen und kritischen Phase
unserer Republik aber einpr ich hab mir
ja die Regierung jetzt zwei Jahre lang
angeguckt auch so im Inneren und ich
fürchte dass sie nicht die Kraft dazu
hat genau das zu tun weil Scholz fürt
fehlt das was er eigentlich versprochen
hat Führung er hat gesagt der bei mir
Führung bestellt bekommt sie auch man
sieht sie aber nicht man sieht sie immer
mal wieder ein wenig Aufflackern siee
zeitenwenderede aber im am Endeffekt
kriegt das nicht durchbuchstabiert er
bekommt auch Lindner und habbeck nicht
diszipliniert legt sie nicht an die
Kandare er lässt sie immer wieder laufen
und dann passieren eben diese Dinge
entweder im Koalitionsausschuss oder nur
die drei ampelmänner verständigen sich
auf etwas und müssen es binnen 24 oder
48 Stunden wieder zurücknehmen weil weil
die weil die Gewalt so groß ist ja aber
das ist der Wunsch ist wirklich ein from
also das ist wirklich ein frommer Wunsch
und ich wollte nur sagen ich sehe das
nicht und
jetzt gab es diese Krisensitzung der SPD
Fraktion zum auftagt des Jahres äh
interessant ist dass tatsächlich dieses
Stillschweigen eingehalten wurde aber
ich glaube da ist den Herrschaften auch
einfach bewusst geworden
dass genau das zutrifft was sie gerade
gesagt haben dass nämlich nicht nur die
Regierung auf dem Spiel steht sondern
dass auch die Demokratie auf dem Spiel
steht weil nämlich das Vertrauen in die
Demokratie aktuell wirklich erodiert wir
sind eine Gesellschaft in der
Zeitenwende in einer heftigen
Transformation siehe Klima siee Verkehr
siehe Digitalisierung
und wenn die Regierung in so einem
Moment es nicht hinbekommt und das sehe
ich nicht dass ich es hinbekommt
zusammenzuhalten und wirklich Führung
vorzugeben die Probleme sind ja schon
groß genug nur wenn die Regierung sich
permanent noch selbst ein Bein stellt
dann funktioniert es nicht und also ich
sehe es tatsächlich nicht ich würde ihn
da Folgen W ganz kurz da hinzufügen darf
wür den da Folgen Frau quadbe ich und
ihnen wiedersprechen Herr sta ich glaube
auch dass dies ein sehr frommer Wunsch
von ien ist zu sagen also die setzen
sich jetzt hin und einigen sich und
sagen das ist unsere letzte Chance die
sind in einem zust an der Panik sie
wissen das viel besser als ich die sind
alle sozusagen an der Grenze des
Verlustes die FDP am meisten die SPD
natürlich auch dramatisch aber auch die
Grünen und der Blick geht nur noch auf
die nächsten umfrageerte und das hat
nichts mehr mit äh mit Politik mit
Sachpolitik zu tun und das ist für mich
äh auch das was ich eingangs gesagt habe
dass sich
hinwursteln jetzt bis zu einem Jahr vor
dem wahlte Termin und dann beginnt ja
ohnehin schon der Wahlkampf und mit
Sachpolitik ist nichts mehr zu machen
also wir sollten hier keine großen
Hoffnungen mehr haben ich habe eine
Hoffnung dass man das Thema Migration
halbwegs in den Griff bekommen kann
vielleicht auch mit Hilfe der Opposition
und dann könnten sich auch die Umfrage
werde
zu Gunsten der Parteien der Mitte ver
darf ich mal einen Aspekt noch aufnehmen
der schon mehrfach gefallen ist Karl
Rudolf Korte was hier alles auf dem
Spiel steht wenn das schief geht oder
wenn es nicht besser wird sich
verschlimmert oder radikalisiert also
gefundenes Fressen für die AFD das ja
gerade in den letzten Tagen besonders
eindrücklich gewesen was da die
wirkliche Alternative
ist wird das überdramatisiert diese
Entwicklung kann man die gar nicht
dramatisch genug sehen wie muss man das
jetzt in diesem ganzen Kontext also wir
haben neue Herausforderung für uns zur
Demokratie ich sehe jetzt nicht die
Erosion und nicht die superkrise aber
Herausforderung über die sich vor allen
Dingen die politische Mitte verständigen
muss die integrationsfähiger werden muss
gegenüber anderen die empathiefähiger
werden muss gegenüber anderen nur die
Defensive gegen die anderen wird am Ende
nicht reichen die AFD ist ein passiver
Profiteur von Angst und die Angst wird
bleiben sie wird darauf weiteretzen und
andere Parteien werden das nachmachen
sie ist Protest provok aber auch
Gesinnungstäter mittlerweile sofern eine
Mischung wenn man das aber weiß kann man
darauf aber auch reagieren und mein gibt
verschiedene Zugänge der eine ist zu
sagen sehen wir uns mal an wie wirklich
Wahlen aus der Mitte heraus bisher
geführt worden sind und auch gewählt
worden ist dann gibt es eine hohe
Risikoaversion es gibt die Wählerin
Wähler die auf Bekanntheit setzen nicht
auf Unbekanntheit die
Ministerpräsidenten auch mit Amtsbonus
honorieren die gegenveränderung sind
eher für Kontinuität die auch Typen
wählen die nicht populistisch
daherkommen sondern eher diese
Extremisten des normal also
sicherheitsdeutsche so und warum soll
sich diese den auch in den größten
Krisen erstmal nicht durchsetzen 5%
haben so in wiesbahn und München auch
gewählt das ist das eine szenar das
andere ist dass durchaus unter den
Rahmenbedingungen dass der Fluch des
wahlkalenders zufällig dazu führt drei
ostwahlen hintereinander zu haben und
noch eine in der Wahlforschung beze
nebenwahl der EU-Wahl die aber auch sehr
zugespitzt gerade in diesen F genau die
auch so eine gerne denkzettelwahl ist
das ist Problem des Kalenders dass man
das hintereinander liegen hat und
deswegen soll man das Problem natürlich
sehen und angehen aber ich kann nicht
erkennen dass dieses grundsätzliche
wahlmuster was bisher die politische
Mitte in Deutschland charakterisiert hat
verloren gegangen ist und noch etwas
anderes sind ja auch begleitmechanismen
denk mal wir werden vielleicht
handballeuropameister vielleicht viicht
wer die migrationszahl im Frühjahr
weniger sichtbar wir werden vielleicht
Europameister im Fußball vielleicht
gewinnt beiden am Ende und wir kriegen
im Januar noch jeder klimageld
ausgezahlt wie in Österreich ja
plötzlich ist doch die Situation anders
ich ich whre mich dagegen dass es immer
nur einseitig runter und
steckelt ja nein in einer komplexen
Gesellschaft gibt es keine Entwicklung
nur besser oder nur schlechter das muss
man einfach mit ein eineisen das sehe
ich schon auch zu großen Teilen so was
ist die AFD die AFD ist ein äh
protestsammelbecken für unzufriedene in
diesem Land die AFD ist
gleichzeitig hat ein Kernelement an
braunen Sumpfgebieten die sie nicht
willens und in der Lage ist
auszutrocknen ich würde sagen vor allem
nicht willens ist sie auszutrocknen ich
verstehe nicht und es ist jetzt keine
wählerbeschimpfung wie man als
differenzierungsfähiger
äh äh Mensch dieses Landes äh sozusagen
sein Kreuzchen dort abgeben kann ich
verstehe es nicht wenn man die
konsellation dieser Partei
sich anschaut und deshalb glaube ich
auch dass es ganz wichtig ist und dass
das ist der zentrale Punkt du musst sie
an ihren Themen
fassen und musst sie dort im Grunde auf
die Absurdität äh und auch die Gefahr
dessen was sie sagen und was sie denken
und was sie formulieren hinweisen und
dann glaube ich auch es ist ja schon mal
gungen diesen Spuk ein wenig einzudämmen
dann wird das ein zweites Mal gelingen
da bin ich sehr sicher natürlich der
Blick auf die drei an aneinander
gereiten Wahlen ist natürlich ein ein
ein separates Problem das wie viel Geld
sollte man auf die Vernunft Wetten in
dem
Zusammenhang schau ich glaube man wenn
man auf die Vernunft wetten möchte dann
müsste man im Kampf gegen die AFD noch
etwas anderes tun oder in der Abwehr
gegen die AFD dann reicht es glaube ich
nicht das ist ein wichtiger Teil dass
man die AFD
dekovriert ja dass man sie entlarft dass
man sagt was das Wort Remigration
tatsächlich in der Realität bedeutet ich
bin mir aber auch sehr sicher dass ähm
dass der Staat whrhafter sein muss gegen
die AFD insbesondere in sozialen
Netzwerken
deutlicher Vorgehen gegen Trolle dort wo
Nester sind von
Verfassungsfeinden muss es ungemütlich
werden für diese Leute da braucht es
ratchen das BKA hat Personal schon
aufgestockt um im Internet Streife zu
gehen ja und das reicht aber bei weitem
noch nicht aus und da muss der Staat
sich noch sehr viel stärker wehren weil
wenn man darauf guckt was sorgt denn im
Moment für die Eskalation der Proteste
beispielsweise der bauernproteste
vielfach kann man es zurückführen auf
Rechte Trolle auf AFD Mitglieder die da
die Leute auf pzen und ich meine die
Bauern die wussten schon immer derbe zu
demonstrieren auch in früheren Jahren
haben wir Traktoren im Regierungsviertel
erlebt aber
dass das dann sich so ausgewirkt hat wie
beispielsweise am fairanleger wo habbeck
versucht hat aus dem Urlaub zu kommen
das hätten die Bauern vor 10 Jahren noch
nicht getan wi da ist mir ein Punkt
wichtig dass wir da schon differenzieren
Frau Quadbeck ich
glaube und das jetzt nicht nur der Blick
jetzt sozusagen in die südliche
Bauernschaft sondern wenn man sich ein
Gesamtüberblick verschafft und
ich habe auch relativ gute Kontakte zum
zum
bauernverbandspräsidenten die achten
schon sehr darauf dass diese
dass diese braunen Unterwanderungen
nicht stattfinden und das haben sie auch
in den letzten Tagen und Wochen getan
das muss man auch immer wieder sagen
weil sonst gibt es da so ein ogu guck
mal das sind die Landwirte und die
lassen hier doch ich würde gerne gote
ganz kurz da unterbrechen wir machen
morgen genau eine vertiefende Sendung
noch zur AFD deswegen würde ich gerne
zuung dazu genau dann war das unser
Trailer gewesen ich würde gerne noch mal
auf ein Aspekt der Ampel Hinweisen den
die Bertelsmann Stiftung vor einigen
Wochen veröffentlicht hat nämlich die
sogenannte Halbzeitbilanz die sieht gar
nicht mal so schlecht aus zwei Drittel
der Vorhaben der Ampel sind nach dieser
Bilanz umgesetzt oder angepackt worden
man hat allerdings auch sehr viel mehr
Vorhaben
ins zzne gesetzt oder sich vorgenommen
weil man ja auch jeder muss sein Senf
dazu geben im Koalitionsvertrag da
mussten auch sie sehr viel mehr
Interessen berücksichtigt werden sie
sollen aber sind ja von einer gewissen
Qualität auch diee Vorhaben auch wegen
des der des Zwangs zur Transformation
und
trotzdem verkauft die Koalition also wir
haben es jetzt mehrfach
angesprochen dieses zu wenig als Erfolg
man sagt immer so gut schön tue Gutes
und rede darüber das tut sie eben nicht
und es geht völlig unter im Moment bei
diesen Umfragen dass doch sich einiges
bewegt hat ja wir haben es ist
tatsächlich eine Situation wo ich aber
auch noch mal drauf hinweisen will
deswegen um noch mal kurz darauf
zurückzukommen ob das jetzt alles
Wunschdenken ist dass diese Regierung
wieder zusammenfindet ich sag mal es war
nicht alles schlecht ja und sie hat auch
wirklich eine ganze Menge auf dem Weg
gebracht und man darf auch nicht
vergessen dass die voräer Regierung bei
der natürlich die SPD auch an einige
Jahre mitbeteiligt war auch verdammt
viel hat liegen lassen das heißt wir
haben einen Reformstau in deut
Deutschland und und gleichzeitig müssen
deshalb die Menschen umso deutlicher
mitgenommen werden und hinzu kamen eben
tatsächlich viele externe Krisen die zu
einem demokratieproblem nicht nur in
Deutschland mir ist das wirklich zu
Deutschland zentriert welche Regierung
funktioniert denn gerade die von sunak
die von
macron das heißt wir haben wir haben
Umwälzungen überall wir haben auch diese
Aggressivität überall in den in der Welt
auch in den Demokratien das heißt es ist
sowieso extrem schwierig zu regieren und
diese Regierung hat in den ersten in dem
ersten Jahr unter einer Vielzahl von
Krisen wirklich gut funktioniert auch
viele Gesetze auf dem Weg gebracht auch
tatsächlich viele von ihren
Versprechungen umgesetzt vieles gilt
jetzt nicht mehr ich glaube auch
keinesfalls an das halt ich auch ein
bisschen für populistisch diese Nummer
die haben den Kontakt zum einfachen
Bürger verloren überhaupt nicht ich
kenne auch viele der agierenden das
stimmt in keinstem Fall das stimmt in
keinstem Fall also die sind
wahrscheinlich dann dran ich weiß es
nicht aber und das andere kommt noch
dazu deswegen glaube ich auch an die
Akteure dass sie das können weil sie
schon bewiesen haben dass sie es können
und Sie haben das Wort Panik genannt ich
kenne Olaf Scholz sehr gut das letzte
was Olaf Scholz empfindet ist Panik das
heißt er ist natürlich auch ein sehr
besondnener Akteur er wird schon wieder
versuchen diese Akteure
zusammenzubringen ich glaube auch dass
alle gehört haben dass es jetzt besser
werden muss und wir haben ja überhaupt
keine Alternative das möchte ich mal
dass sie am anf anfangs gesagt der
Wahlerfolg beruhte auf dem desolaten
Zustand der Union ja ist der denn heute
besser nächste Frage
gewesen dass eine Opposition ja
jederzeit nach der politischen Theorie
bei uns in der Lage sein muss die
Regierung zu übernehmen ob jetzt mit
oder ohne Wahlen es gibt ja auch noch
andere Möglichkeiten durch das
konstruktive Misstrauensvotum aber sie
muss in der Lage sein Karl Rudolf Karte
ist sie denn in der Lage ist das was die
Union jetzt anbietet Heidelberger
Erklärung vom vergangenen Wochen
da hat ja gesagt vor allen Dingen was
sie alles nicht will dass sie das
heizungsgesetz Zurücknehmen möchte und
das Bürgergeld wieder kassieren ist denn
das was sie da anbietet sie muss soll ja
eine Alternative sein man wirft ja immer
vor die werden alle abgeschliffen die
Parteien der Mitte und wden alles
Gleiche wollen jetzt will sie eine
Alternative sein ist das etwas was die
Union perspektivisch ihr gute Chancen
gibt demnächst die Regierung wieder zu
übernehmen also normalerweise wäre ja
erwartbar wenn der Unmut so ist wie wir
ih im Moment messen können dass davon
auch die klassische Opposition mehr
profitiert als nur 30%. das ist nicht
der Fall sie verharren praktisch und
sofern trauen viele auch der Opposition
nicht die Regierungsverantwortung
offenbar zu und auch nicht dem Personal
dass sie jetzt den Kanzler stellen das
ist das grundsätzliche Problem wenn man
sich mit der Opposition auseinandersetzt
kooperative Opposition wird belohnt sie
haben auch viele zentrale Dinge mit der
Regierung zusammengemacht fundamentale
wird er abgelehnt insofern wird der
Druck auf die Union von den Bürgern auch
zunehmen mit der Regierung auch mehr
noch zusammenzuarbeiten und dann wird
auch die Wahlchancen für die Union
zunehmen durch mehr Kooperation nicht
durch reine OP könnte auch der Kanzler
davon profitieren ja und es kommt
natürlich hinzu dass die Union nach so
vielen langen Jahren des Regierens sich
ein neues Programm zu allen Themen
praktisch er arbeiten eine eigene
Positionierung und natürlich auch vor
der Frage steht wer sie am Ende anführt
für den kommenden Wahlkampf auch das
macht sie im Moment nicht schlüssig nur
einig in jedem Punkt diese Personalfrage
ist ja nicht wirklich geklärt es gibt ja
da auch unterschiedliche Strömungen
friedich merärz denkt ganz anders als
G wüst auch politisch inhaltlich
hat es der Union denn geholfen diese
eher konservative Linie die im Moment
der Parteivorsitzende verkörpert wieder
in den Vordergrund zu stellen ich glaube
dass der Union gegenüber der Ampel eine
eher konservative Linie tatsächlich
hilft aber ich
denke dass was nicht hilft ist die Art
wie Friedrich Merz sie kommuniziert mit
Schlagwörtern wie kleine Paschas da geht
es um den Zahnersatz und da gibt es ja
noch mehr Beispiele wo er die Leute auf
die Bäume treibt und
dann wird immer über diese Begriffe
diskutiert und die das ganz Deutschland
das ganze Netz regt sich auf über diese
Begriffe man diskutiert darüber aber
über das eigentliche Problem und die
eigentlichen auch politischen Anliegen
und auch ja teilweise Lösungsvorschläge
die die Union dazu hat wird eben nicht
gesprochen und und das sorgt dann noch
dafür dass Friedrich märz nicht als
hinreichend seriös wahrgenommen wird
wenn er in dieser Art und Weise
kommuniziert und wenn sein
Generalsekretär der eigentlich dafür
zuständig wäre vielleicht gelegentlich
mal sowas loszulassen dann wiederum sein
Parteichef ständig überall erklären muss
und das ist das Problem ist den genügend
Vertrauen schon entstanden zwischen CDU
und CSU nach den Vorgängen des Sommers
unwahrscheinlich es ist
es ist ein weites Feld um mit Fontane zu
reden äh das sind zwei Schwestern die
versuchen sich sozusagen mit Blick auf
äh die kommenden Wahlkämpfe
entsprechend ähm zu zu einigen zu
einigen ich glaube eines kann man sagen
dass äh Markus Söder äh im Hinterkopf
für sich geklärt hat äh dass er kein
Kandidat äh mehr sein wird das glaube
ich stört das kann man so sehen und das
ist sicherlich auch eine Frage dann wie
weit die CDU das überhaupt zuliee sie
würde es nämlich nicht mehr zulassen
nachdem was 21
war
das ist schon das ist schon ein
wichtiger Punkt aber ich finde man
sollte den Leuten doch auch mal sagen
streit gehört zur Demokratie und wenn
Friedrich März nun mal einen rauslässt
und zuspitzt und man darüber diskutiert
was haben wir früher für Diskussionen
gehabt Strauß weder
Brand Helmut Schmidt ja dann tut das
einer Demokratie doch nur gut und jetzt
damals hatten wir aber noch nicht Social
Media das ist wahr und jetzt wage ich
eine steile These auch der Streit in der
Koalition ist möglicherweise von Fall zu
Fall durchaus hilfreich um Standpunkte
abzuklären um
Positionen gegeneinander abzustimmen
warum denn keinen Streit an dessen Ende
ein guter Kompromiss steht das ist doch
das ist doch politische äh Kommunikation
wenn wir schon dauernd darüber reden ja
gut nur lasch war kein guter Kompromiss
also der letzte Streit der letzte große
Streit der Union und
das was bei der Ampel rauskommt erweist
sich meistens auch nicht als guter
Kompromiss wenn ein guter Kompromiss
Sünde dann wäre es ja wunderbar und dann
würde sie ja auch durchhalten dann würde
sie in der Öffentlichkeit ja auch die
Kommunikation durchhalten und nicht beim
beim ersten Traktor tuten Einknicken der
Kanzler wird sich wie wir ihn alle
kennen nicht ändern aber dieser
erklärgeiz der ihn ausprägt dieses hat
aggressiv zu schweigen ist ja eine
Schwierigkeit für uns damit umzugehen
aber er hätte es eigentlich in der Hand
weil der Bedarf nach einem krisenlotzen
der das schlössig erklärt um was es geht
mit den aldilemmata wie es der
Vizekanzler idealtypisch jeden Tag
vormacht danach lächzen wir geradezu und
dann würden wir auch verstehen warum
befristet das ein od andere schlechter
werden warum eine Demokratie mit einer
verlustkompetent zukünftig umgehen muss
wenn wir das weniger haben und nicht das
mehr das wäre seine Aufgabe Staus
vielleicht kann man ja ist gar nicht so
steil die These zu sagen dass Olaf
Scholz vor allen Dingen seinem
politischen Gegner von der Union den
Wahlsieg äh verdankt äh zumindestens
dass es die stärkste Partei WD und er
dann Kanzler setzt er vielleicht daran
so eine Hoffnung dass ich das Wahljahr
2021 noch mal wiederholen könnte 2025 es
gibt keine Wahl die sich wiederholt
insofern würde ich allen die daran
glauben mal ganz schnell wieder
widersprechen jede Wahl ist ein Unikat
und wir haben eine völlig andere
Situation ähm dann bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl all wir es als wir es bei
der letzten hatten nach 16 Jahren Merkel
ähm und einem Feld dass die Leute sich
komplett neu anschauen mussten ohne ein
Kanzler deranttrat und ohne einen
Kanzler deranttrat und ausdem Sie dann
die Leute betrachtet und gemessen haben
und gesagt haben na ja die kann es nicht
der kann es auch nicht im zsfall nehmen
wir halt den weil der am längsten dabei
ist und auf uns den Eindruck macht der
kann es so und das ist genau die Gefahr
ähm dass ähm dass das Scholz eben mit
diesem Nimbus reingegangen ist der kann
es der jetzt beschädigt ist der stark
beschädigt ist und den er und da bin ich
bei Professor Korte den er am Ende nur
selbst sich wieder erarbeiten kann und
dem sich auch diese Koalition n
wiederarbeiten kann wir haben in machen
ja auch viel Wahlforschung wir haben in
der Bevölkerung Deutschland keinen
Wunsch dass diese Regierung abgewählt
wird wir haben den Wunsch dass sie
funktioniert und es gibt auch keine
Sehnsucht in der Bevölkerung nach ander
ken gr K leider kein neues F mehr
aufmachen wir sind am Ende der Sendung
bedanke mich bei Frank Staus bei Eva
Quadbeck bei dli bei Karl Rudolf Korte
liebe zuschauerinn liebe Zuschauer
morgen in der phöniixrunde Gefahr von
rechts gehört die AFD
verboten aktuelles bei Anja ch in Phönix
der Tag darin unter anderem Europäisches
Parlament Weltwirtschaftsforum Inter und
die US Vorwahlen in Iowa bleiben Sie bei
uns
[Musik]